who actually killed artie was it was it
tim or k-pod
which i'm pretty sure was tim uh
dude i don't remember oh the laptop way
yeah in the open oh how did it oh yeah
yeah i just got switched
all right so we're voting out uh
tunnel right no
uh to the people on twitch i can't join
a squad stream because i'm not partnered
so
let me take any solo out here i do not
have the option sadly also let me know
if my audio levels are alright
i feel like they're okay but what do i
know had a hell of a busy day today
okay i'll let y'all do that leave
but i do have tasks in here though this
is such a good place to die
my gosh
just a great place to just get murdered
when you're just trying to hang out
do a task okay that i feel like clear's
mega bit
like that would have been a great place
to [ __ ] me up
[Music]
i feel like they just keep updating this
game like i've never had this happen
before
what why there we go
oh my gosh i found gavin up
in weapons
weapons wow so someone killed
immediately
and then they killed him yeah
but oh everybody did an admin
uh i mean there's completely alone on
the top left who found the body did you
pass anyone in that area
so i found the body but i didn't i was
going through a cafeteria though and it
was
right at the end of the round so it like
it could have been early
mm-hmm oh you were going
no cafeteria to weapons sorry oh okay
man is jackie and i are in admin right
now
yeah i've been electrical the whole game
and then i went to admin
how was the one on the right side
i just was going to the right side well
there was a right
right side yeah i mean is
yeah true i don't like saying self
report but like that's the only
information we have right now
no one knows seriously it wasn't me
it's a bit suspicious
i know
i don't feel good about it but here we
are all right
voting is more dangerous it's all
processed it's still pretty simple i
would say excessive tripod to be honest
all right just whoever it is keep that
in mind
follow me i'm going to web i followed
[ __ ]
i'm not actually sure if not jackie is
jackie i'm just assuming that that is
actually jackie
i don't know all of these people okay
i still gotta go to that upper engine
daddy
oh gosh oh jackie okay
i feel bad about what i did to her last
round which i know isn't
how this game works but i got guilt
everybody's
just fine i was just about to call a
meeting
i found it in comms i went to add i went
to navigation back to admin
checked admin to see that there was
someone in comms electrical
security and upper engine and then
immediately went down to
calm first to check and see who was
there and it was pink and they're dead
so he did he went into the weapons room
didn't do the weapon thing he did the
thing on like the right side wall
then i went down into nav and he kept
going down there so if he died
it was probably pretty recent
i'm now 100 sure it's tim
when the doors closed on me and you and
me could you tell if jackie went left or
right
i went right and then i went down to
electrical and did two tests
uh yeah because jackie madness and i
went into
med knee and alfredo got stuck in there
we got stuck in there
and then i went down to electrical i
don't know where you're getting stuff
from me it's i
did that round
um i saw tim and tripod and weapons so
his story checks out he was there
watching
him try to do that um i came back i went
to navigation did two tasks
went back from navigation up through
weapons to see if pink or any of them
were dead no one was there
went down to admin and then to comms
he's saying he went to navigation he
would have passed me
there's no way we impressed each other
we did
me and tripod passed you i went into nab
as you were leaving nav and he kept
going down
i did my test plotting the chorus
putting the little
like crosshair on the thing either
you're not fighting me or i'm an idiot
you literally walked past the
just hanging out by myself largely you
were the last person i think i paused to
send alfredo i'm loading a water because
we have to and it's we have no
oh my god what where did this come from
that was so undeserved
[ __ ] [ __ ] like lose more than this
group
should lose oh my god what the [ __ ]
that turned on you do anything
i think you know what i'm not gonna do
my tasks just to [ __ ] them
i'm not going to do my talks the same
way you [ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
let the reactor go on i've never seen
anything like that
oh my god oh my
[Music]
oh my god
so rude my scream wants to know
legitimately tim did you [ __ ] with your
game files to get imposters so
i wish i wasn't i wanted to play this
whole night just following jacket around
every single game and i haven't gotten a
chance to do that
dude how i locked myself in with madness
to gain his trust
oh my god i hate how smart he is
out here i mean all he had to do that
last time was say where has alana been
it wasn't even that smart you're all too
gullible
why didn't you vote they had so much
time and i was like
it was too late towards the end there
was only eight seconds left and you said
yeah everyone everyone
entire time that was the problem yeah
but i didn't see [ __ ]
that's why yeah yeah by myself
early on and said exactly where you were
maybe that wouldn't have happened i
always forget where i am is the problem
all the time i'm like i don't know i'm
dead